زياده في الدعم الى اوكرانيا في مواجهه
موسكو الرئيس الاوكراني اكد ان كيف حصلت
على الدعم من 20 دوله في قمه الامن
الغذائي وان القمه جمعت 150 مليون دولار
لارسال الغذاء الى الدول التي تعيش ازمه
غذائيه بسبب الحرب
السياسه العباده الجماعيه الجديده لروسيا
نحن لا نصد العدوان فقط
العدوان ويكسر عواقبه ويضمن الامن على
المدى الطويل لاوكرانيا واوروبا والعالم
باسره
زهره قاده اوروبيون كيف لاحياء ذكرى
المجاعه التي تسبب بها ستالين وتعتبرها
اوكرانيا عباده جماعيه الزياره تركز على
موجه جديده محتمله من الهجره الاوكرانيه
الى اوروبا هذا الشتاء وتاتي بعد اعلان
المستشار الالماني عن تقديم مساعدات
اضافيه بقيمه عشره ملايين يورو كييف لدعم
صادرات الحبوب
تقف فرنسا والمانيا معا الى جانب اوكرانيا
ونعمل بلا كلر لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا
اولوياتنا الحاليه هي استعاده البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه
بدورها قالت ان فرنسا دعمت اوكرانيا منذ
البدايه وانها ستبقى على دعمها حتى نهايه
هذا الصراع اما الرئيس الروسي فالتقى
بامهات عسكريين للمره الاولى مؤكدا لهن
انه يشاركهن الالم ودعاهن الى عدم تصديق
الاكاذيب
والخ الداعي والاكاذيب المعلومات هي ايضا
سلاح وهجمات المعلومات هي وسيله فعاله
للقتال الخارجيه الروسيه من جهتها نددت
بقرار البرلمان الاوروبي وصف روسيا بانها
دوله راعيه للارهاب